if that were true that would still be
completely irrelevant to the question of
what we do about poverty
[Music]
you could use example about education as
a solution of poverty this is a um you
know this is something that you see all
over the place
uh in mainstream political discourse uh
from
you know somebody who's you know go back
to the 15 an hour issue you know you see
some fast food workers protesting
for um you know higher wages trying to
form a union uh and you're deeply
unpleasant Uncle says oh if they
um if they wanted to make more money
they should go back to school
and you know and and get you know
and you know go into a different
profession Etc right
there's the nice that's the very deeply
unpleasant version of it this nice
liberal version of it which is like uh
Barack Obama at one of his State of the
Union addresses says that the best
anti-poverty program that's ever been
devised is a world-class education
everybody claps because that's the kind
of thing that when you say it everybody
claps
but in both cases you're assuming that
education and upward Mobility
can be a solution to poverty
now one possible response to that is to
say well
okay in many cases that may for a
variety of reasons be unrealistic and
that's true as far as it goes right lots
of people for lots of reasons you know
can't do that
but that doesn't really get at the nub
of the issue
something that does get at the numb of
the issue that's actually helpfully
clarified if you learn a little bit of
logical terminology is
even if it were true of every single
person right every single person living
in poverty no exceptions of any kind
could let's assume for the sake of
argument
go to school and I don't know become a
doctor or lawyer or something and you
know make make excellent money
if that were true that would still be
completely irrelevant to the question of
what we do about poverty
say that again make sure everybody's
clear on the point that would still be
completely irrelevant if it were true
because even if it's true of any
individual person that they could do
that
it does not follow it is in fact a named
logical fallacy the composition fallacy
to think that it follows
that every person living in poverty
could do that right
um the composition fallacies where you
say every member of a group has some
property therefore the group as a whole
has it right
so
every molecule in the Brooklyn Bridge Is
invisible therefore you know the
Brooklyn Bridge must be invisible
and same deal even if we accept the
false premise every single person living
in poverty could be you know go to
school and be upwardly mobile
it would still be false that every
person living in poverty could go to
school and be upwardly mobile
because for one thing we'd all starve to
death right you know nobody would be
growing food nobody would be
transporting it to the grocery store
nobody would be stocking on the Shelf of
that grocery store Etc
it's structurally impossible in a
capitalist Society for everybody to have
the better off positions you know you
cannot have every you know cheerleader
on the top of the pyramid at the same
time that's uh
so
you know you could either do something
to actually lift the floor for everybody
do something structural along the lines
let's talk about earlier
or admit that you're doing something
other than trying to come up with
something to say about poverty as an
actual phenomenon
um what I mentioned earlier is called
the Continuum fallacy that's the idea
uh that's where you conclude from the
existence of gray areas and unclear
cases that aren't real distinctions and
aren't clear cases
so those are a couple of examples
but I think one reason why some people
on the left uh some people who are
good-hearted people who have good
political commitments are somewhat
resistant to thinking in these terms and
you know and to
um and to think that this could be
important right to uh to think about and
study uh this kind of terminology to
think about arguments on this level
is because of a widespread cultural
perception that logic or whatever people
think logic is is somehow in tension
with feelings emotions all that stuff
um
that telling people to be more logical
is telling them to care less about all
of that right
in favor of something else and this is
something some people on the right
weaponize like crazy you know for their
own purposes you know they uh
um you know another Ben right Ben
Shapiro you know has this uh this kind
of this catchphrase facts don't care
about your feelings which is meant to
suggest that fuzzy headed leftists uh
draw their political conclusions on the
basis of their feelings whereas people
like him derive them
from the cold hard facts and of course
it's true the facts don't care about
your feelings they also don't care about
other facts they don't care about
anything uh they're just facts uh the
question surely is what human beings
should care about and there it's
actually a principle of logic it's uh
called hume's law that you cannot
logically derive
a conclusion that's an ought that's
about right or wrong good or bad what's
just or unjust
from an is from a claim about facts done
work if you don't have some sort of if
you don't care about some sort of values
or goals that the facts are irrelevant
you know the facts are always there in a
supporting role
that
um you know if you think that
um
the life of a um of a human being is
always more important than anything else
than
you know some facts about you know fetal
developments might be terribly relevant
to how you come down on abortion rights
if you think that bodily autonomy right
there I control what's going on in your
own body can Trump that
not right that's an argument about
values
I think the last point that I'd like to
make here is that the fact that there
are always some sort of values there's
always some sort of goal that you care
about that's in the driver's seat right
logic is about figuring out what follows
from what but you know any argument is
exactly as good as its starting point
odd facts can play a supporting role but
there is always some sort of underlying
value commitment
some people think that that means that
well it's just sort of pointless to
argue with people who fundamentally
disagree with your values you know
what's the point doesn't matter if you
show
you know that the um if you have
impeccable reasoning right you know they
still disagree with the underlying value
commitment and so that's that I think
it's I think kind of the opposite is
true which takes us back to persuasion
uh so Elizabeth brunig is a um socialist
writer in the U.S and she has a good
line about how half the point of a
debate is to get the other person to
tell you what they really think
and I think very often actually drawing
out the implications of people's
positions is incredibly useful for
exposing those underlying gaps in value
commitments so that once you get to the
point where you know I'll just take an
example of a debater watched a while ago
between Sam Cedar and someone from the
Ein Rand Institute uh where the at the
end they were talking about it this uh
collapse that had just happened in Miami
this condo collapse a bunch of people
have died you know because the because
the condos had collapsed because of
unsafe
construction practices and Sam asks yarn
Brook that's the person from the Iran
Institute okay so is this a legitimate
role for the regulatory state
it says no because uh ultimately that's
the responsibility
of
um you know that's the responsibility of
those tenants that if they were
concerned about safety they should have
checked to you know see what the safety
practices were and how often it had been
inspected and you know and all of that
and that's incredibly useful because the
point of a debate is never to convince
the person you're arguing with that
happens but very slowly right
it's to convince people who are watching
and I think if you showed that they
fundamentally don't care about the
things that most human beings would care
about you know to my mind that's a win
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas